are you film to that reunion yeah still
stand-in Oh
always always honey I'm a hard female
dog to knock over for two years I have
held a secret about you Leanne so I'm
gonna reveal it right now why don't you
jump in a lake and drowned I'm still
alive I can't wait alive you've no idea
it was I mean it was intense
you never had a opinion all year and now
all the sudden you got plenty I still AM
shaky from the reunion I literally I'm
still having a hard time sleeping how
would you describe the reunion this year
loud loud if I sold your phone I would
have taken it back to America and got
into it okay [ __ ]
and a lot of lives you said that you
heard from multiple people that rich had
been on fit he's never cheated both of
his ex-wives came to me and sought me
out and told me different stories they
said to me you have no idea what you're
saving her from
it was a really great reunion I have to
say I think we kept Andy 100%
entertained the entire time I mean he
was like at some point I think he
thought where are these girls from like
Dallas the guy who said that mark gets
his dick sucked at the roundup was a
disgruntled with a disgruntled florist
if you can believe that
there any other kind there wasn't a lot
of resolution I feel like so I was gonna
say did you walk away with more
questions than answers 100% I walked
away feeling like I didn't get enough
time to talk you know I feel like a lot
of people didn't have that chance to
really explain themselves so there's a
lot that's unfinished I hate the word
society I didn't have a lot of questions
when I went in I was hoping to find a
lot of resolution and I think you'll
have to wait and see them see what I
guess if you walk away on good terms
okay terms with DeAndre you guys are
gonna have to see your couch took a
picture together after but I answer you
with any of those other ladies on the
other couch well I'll let you guys just
wonder but before the reunion there's
the season finale do you think that
you're better than guys devour don't
shoot
get out of my face it looks like it's
gonna be Brandi versus LeAnn part 3 oh
my god is it not Brandi versus LeAnn
part nine hundred and eighty-five
thousand six hundred and forty two point
one over it like seriously you have a
baby like do something Randy has chosen
that she is just not gonna like me and
instead of actually accepting it herself
that she just doesn't like me and just
literally not doing anything with me I
feel like the entire Target store arrows
flying everywhere
put your dodge up I don't have to dodge
them honey got off this shield
I ain't seen an arrow penetrate yet you
always always are the one-liners Oh
make one-liners
[Music]